all right here's an article from the
badger Herald
it says as the University of Washington
of Wisconsin campus prepares to host
Matt Walsh a right-wing political
commentator
members of the lgbtq and gender
non-conforming communities on campus
have expressed feelings of hurt and
concern recent targeted incidents
towards the group have exacerbated these
emotions
so there have been targeted incidents
the University of Wisconsin I'll be
speaking there I remember the exact date
I'll be speaking there soon as we
continue the our what is a woman tour
and we'll be announcing some more dates
by the way and some more schools pretty
soon
but apparently in the lead up to my uh
to my speech and screening the film at
University of Wisconsin there have been
there have been there have been targeted
incidents at vulnerable populations
let's find out what those incidents are
upon arriving at Sterling Hall Monday
October 10th
um
people with the gender women's studies
Department someone named Jessica Leeper
found the gender women's studies floor
covered in posters for the Walsh event
that's the that's the targeted incident
so somebody went in at University of
Wisconsin uh presumably you know a
supporter maybe a member of the sweet
baby gang there at University of
Wisconsin went into the went to the
gender women's studies department and
just and and
covered the place in what is a woman
posters
that is uh I cannot I don't know if I
can officially endorse that or not
but I will because that's fantastic
when Libra first arrived she only saw a
couple of posters and she said she was
annoyed but not surprised but upon
further investigation she found that
every bulletin board and chalkboard in
the hallway had been covered in the
posters I think we have some pictures
we'll put up for you too well while
Libra did not count the exact number of
posters she took down she estimated that
it was at least 40. Libra filed only one
or two event posters in the other
departments in Sterling
so this is this is the incident that
happened
uh continuing along
according to leaper there's a lot of
hurt anger and exhaustion among the TA
students in the department
quote any credibility the university had
in an academic commitment to providing
speakers of diverse opinions is lost in
the wake of Monday's targeted Act of
hate speech it's a target of active
behave speech to just put up a poster
for my event
but you know what go back they took them
all down go back and uh I'm calling on
the sweet babe again go go back and put
the posters back just keep putting them
back up there
take them down put them up
hey this is this is fair play because
the left constantly tears down the
posters no matter what campus I go to no
matter where the posters are put up the
leftists come along and tear them down
so this is the game you want to play
this is what we'll play
she continued yaf has now with this
action made it abundantly clear that
their goal with bringing Walsh to campus
is to intimidate and endanger the trans
and gender non-conforming community
explain that to me uh Jessica Leeper I
want you to explain and maybe you can
you know maybe you can explain it
but explain in precise detail how you
have been endangered
by seeing a poster by seeing a small
like a piece of paper
a yellow piece of paper that says what
is a woman how does that endanger you
can you can you
can you elaborate I'd like to hear you
elaborate on that
if you can if you can prove to me
that simply and I don't know how this
would work physically okay I don't know
what the physical mechanism is I I don't
know the science behind it but maybe you
can describe it maybe you can explain to
me if you can prove to me that simply
seeing the poster will lead directly to
physical harm or death
if you can prove that to me then maybe I
would call I would I would call off the
sweet baby gang and say stop putting the
posters up
I don't want to have you know I I don't
want there to be bodies all over the
place people that have hurt and dying
because they saw a poster so if you can
explain that then I'd love to hear it
um Lee profiled a bias incident report
to the dean of students the report asked
the school to take the incident
seriously as a targeted Act of hate
speech and revoke he asked permission to
use the Great Hall for their event
there has not been any follow-up to the
report at this time
um
oh and then we have more interviews with
the General Studies professor of
Department this is all great a student
in the gender women's studies Department
who wished to remain anonymous due to
privacy and safety concerns said that
more than anything they were concerned
for the safety and well-being of the
trans non-binary and GNC community on
campus
uh quote we were already upset about
Walsh with an explicitly anti-trans
project coming to campus and to me the
event organizers bringing their hate
directly to this space just furthers my
concern over the whole event and the
University's ongoing lack of care for
its marginalized students
you know there is uh when you want to
get over a phobia
um
there's well I think what they call
exposure therapy or something like that
but if you're if you're really afraid of
something and this is what they this is
what they tell you in Psychology that
the only way to get over the fear is to
just is to be exposed to it like if you
want if you're I have Arachnophobia I
admit I you know it's one of my least
manly qualities I really don't like
spiders if I actually wanted to get over
that I would have to be exposed to a
spider you know maybe have a tarantula
crawling on my hand or something like
that
I feel like that would traumatize me
more but I'm told that that's one way to
get over the phobia and so I guess my
point is that what I would say to the
students at the gender studies
Department the University of Wisconsin
for whatever reason you are afraid of
these posters you have a fear of posters
and I I think for your own sake because
I am concerned about you and I am
worried about your mental health deeply
and so I think the only way to get you
over that fear
is for more and more of these posters to
be put up in the gender studies
department for your own sake
okay there were 40 posters before next
we got to put 100 up
how are you going to go through life
having this fee if seeing a poster can
can cause you to dissolve into a puddle
I don't know how you function in life so
I want to help you get over that
you're welcome
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block
thanks for watching have a great day
Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]